my name is frank kelly and i'm here with
Giles so we're talking about us you
could say a small project we've been
working on that puts data science to a
good cause really it's and it's a cause
that I've been personally affected by
and we think it's very much worthwhile
so we'll explain a bit about what we've
been doing we're going to talk a bit
about the way we've looked at this
problem and identified features and then
built some models and then try to draw
conclude conclusions and we'll share
some of our findings and results okay
sure this is better now okay so what is
our goal with this so we ideally we want
to develop a way using data to diagnose
Alzheimer's disease as early as possible
so a little bit of background about
Alzheimer's disease it affects millions
of people around the world it's the most
common form of dementia say seventy
percent of dementia is Alzheimer's
usually there's a quite a shocking
statistic in the UK there are about
800,000 people in the formally diagnosed
sure is that better so in the UK there's
about 800,000 people who've been
formally diagnosed but there's perhaps a
million more who who have symptoms of
Alzheimer's and yet they don't really
know and they may go all the way through
to sort of chronic stage of Alzheimer's
without being formally diagnosed or
treated which is quite a shocking
situation I'm sure you'd agree so
and it's it's going to get worse
unfortunately if you look at population
demographics so the chart on the left is
is showing that as as populations get
older around the world so the ratio of
people who can care for people have
things like dementia is is is is
diminishing so that that's the ratio
dependence on the left on the right
country like Japan you're going to see
ya the number of people suffering from
something like Alzheimer's dementia is
going to triple so this is a huge
problem so who are we I've introduced
myself and Giles earlier but there's a
couple of other people working with us
on this you can say it's a part-time
side project so we get together once
every three weeks or if at best every
two weeks over on line one of us is in
Canada the girl there Mya and there's a
tap on the right he's in Spain we're
both in the London area but we managed
to get online and do a little bit of
hacking and playing the data and so it's
really this is just a project on the
side we're not no major promises about
what we can achieve with it but it's
we're here to share what we've what
we've done so in terms of our yeah are
thinking so outside of disease today is
usually diagnosed by a trip to a GP so
starting with they look at you your
medical history they'll perform some
tests and it you know it's it's a
one-time event so you come in you have a
test and you've you've suddenly you've
got out Simon's you diagnosed and
eventually you know you can go up to
doing brain imaging and eventually
dissecting the brain to really confirm
that Alzheimer's has taken place but we
know that at all times is really a it's
a gradual decline occurring in the brain
and so the diagnosis period is
you know usually between say 13 years
and six years before the person dies but
if you look it can occur you know it
often happens up to 20 years before that
the conditions start to happen so there
are many benefits from you know earlier
diagnosis not only in terms of the
individual and their families in terms
of their planning and responsibilities
and you know they're reducing their
anxieties also there's there are
interesting developments in terms of
drugs that may be able to slow down the
effect of the disease and if if more
people can start to be on drug trials
earlier than then I think that bodes
well and you know potential cure you
will be closer to looking at cures and
really ways to it tackle it so looking a
bit of a dar so we how do we start out
so we we thought we'd look into the
domain area get a bit of knowledge
before diving in to you know creating
features and doing some analysis so
Alzheimer's really manifests itself by
while delete the leading hypothesis is
that you have these protein plaques that
cumulates in the brain and they really
disrupt communication between cells I'm
not sure whether they actually kill
cells I'm not domain expert understand
there's been some experiments when they
manage to stimulate neurons in the brain
and they and memories were able to be
brought back afterwards on mice so I'm
not sure how and I don't think even the
leading experts entirely understand the
cause or the impact of the disease but
what we do know is that it starts at one
part of the brain which is the
hippocampus so this is where where our
recent memories
perform and then and so that so the
earliest symptoms you see is short term
memory loss difficult to people having
trouble recollecting certain recent
events and then the disease process
progresses through the front part of the
brain and moves on to areas such as
language processing and and eventually
goes through logical thought emotions
the senses and and on to sort of older
memory the rate of decline we know it
varies for men and women that's been
recently discovered but eventually of
course this will lead to full shutdown
at the brain because the even the sort
of life support systems will be
eventually shut down so how do we turn
this into a to a data science problem
well we think we took all the symptoms
that we could read about in various
papers and we try to match them roughly
with this timeline it's all very
approximate but we we try to think about
where we might get some data and we
start with the idea of written
correspondence because it's already
digital easy to access so in terms of
what we could pick out from people's
written correspondence we selected these
features so starting it's also trying to
find features that were tally with early
early at the earliest symptoms and that
part of the condition so these three so
so language problems so memory issues
and change in sentiment and mood where
areas we decide to focus on
so previously I don't know if some of
you come to the PI data meet up so i did
a lightning talk and we started up by
picking up a single Alzheimer's
sufferers emails and doing some analysis
so we converted emails to two vectors
and eventually counts and numbers and
and extracted a few features so here we
got readability over time over so VA the
age for the patient was between 78 and
82 and yes she's actually the
grandmother of one of the people
collaborating on this team the thing is
well so we saw some there's some example
emails there that we were looking at for
example we saw some sort of trends over
these four years it's hard to really be
conclusive and looking at email in
general we made a lot of inquiries and
we spoke to some organizations about
getting access to volunteers emails the
problem is people there's a lot of
security concerns and and people
actually often delete their emails so we
decided to to change tack slightly so
I'm going to head over to Giles now
let's go talk about our approach
okay so yeah one of the big issues where
the email is how do you get hold of it
and that's pretty tricky so we looked
around for other places we could get the
data from and the Alzheimer Society UK
forums was the most accessible place
where we could get a lot of written data
produced by both sufferers and non
sufferers of dementia so we've used the
I have a partner with dementia sub forum
as our counterpoint to the I have
dementia sub forum which we hope will
allow us to control some extent for age
and education of the subjects so there
was an initial LOL XML scraper that we
used and we rewrote this later into a
beautiful soup which basically made it
easier for us to get more content from
these posts so we scraped to sub-forums
3600 threads approximately and about
thirty percent of those were started by
sufferers of dementia or at least that
was the sub forum they were in and
78,000 posts unfortunately the majority
of those as you might expect from non
sufferers or are they in the non
sufferers the partners forum so we
grabbed the post content the metadata
the user metadata and output that locked
to a couple of rather sizable data
frames well sighs of or not perhaps in
terms of big data but some that gave us
something to play with
so beautiful soups made things very easy
for us we did a little bit of text
cleaning but not very much required just
the bare minimum to put things into an l
TK basically we removed the quotes from
the posts you can imagine that good to
contaminate any signal quite
significantly and use rare gaps just a
tidy stuff up a little bit nothing
complicated so you've got the user
metadata frame or small chunk of it up
on the right there you can see that we
have issues with some posters post a lot
and other posters only post once or
twice so we do have issues with various
biases in the data and the actual post
content with the record of the the
thread it's in the post count is very
important so the first post in the
thread is the one that we prefer to use
to classify a user if they've started a
thread in the in either sub forum we can
probably assume that there we can
classify them appropriate to that sub
forum where as if they're replying then
they could be a dementia sufferer
replying in the partners forum or vice
versa so that's pretty difficult so
labeling the users is a bit of an issue
okay actually Frank this is yours so so
yeah we determined a source of data and
what was our strategy well we just
wanted to engineer some features that
would match the symptoms I've described
and we wanted to somehow aggregate these
posts in a way that could be analyzed
and have features extracted for them in
a meaningful fashion we also wanted to
select a few models and do some
classification so something on user
classification here jealous you want to
talk about that so how do we label users
so unfortunately individual users really
sorry fortunately individual users
rarely start threats in both subforums
if they do we discard them so there's
only 12 in that case so we don't lose
too many users but replies in both
subforums are common and so if we look
at some examples here we can see that
the first user in this frame 18 Roy well
he's only posted in the partner forum so
that's fine we can classify him as a
partner he started the thread and he's
replied a couple of times as well Mindy
that's fairly clear she started 13
threads and although she's replied to a
few posts in the the partners of sorry
the dementia sufferers forum she's
replied to a lot more in the the
partners for him so we can confidently
think that she's a partner to jay's so
this one if you were not being too
cautious you would classify as a partner
of a dementia suffer because of the
ratio of posts here
but in fact we've taken a cautious
approach and it's a compromise between
the quality and the quantity of data we
have but we've thrown at anything that's
ambiguous like that 53 sharon has
started and replied to threads only in
the dementia forum so we're pretty
confident that's a dementia sufferer and
sixties child is a really difficult one
because they haven't started any threads
and they posted almost equally in each
sub forum so unfortunately that's data
that we we wouldn't use so in summary we
discard users who start threads in both
forums we also currently leaving out
users who replied to threads in both
subforums we could use those that
predominantly reply in one sub forum but
for reliability it doesn't give us much
extra to work with so we've just been
that data so that gives us unfortunately
to quite biased groups of users we have
a lot more partners of sufferers but
it's something to work with so over to
Frank
so
once we established more or less
whoo-hoo a user is whether they're a
sufferer or partner we weren't entirely
sure we didn't manually go through every
single post as this jar said but we
gotta you know we were fairly confident
about our initial data we decided to
design some features so to start with we
just put some very basic features to do
with counting counting words council
censuses and unique words workout and
encouragingly we plot histogram of posts
we see differences straightaway so we
see that sufferers are generally they
seem to be writing longer sentences
which sounds strange but it might be we
figure because they're not maybe using
punctuation as as often as their partner
for example so you see a sort of a wider
spread more more variation there's
things like yeah sentiment there's a
package called text blog you can just
pull out and you can it's a fairly basic
procedure you're able to analyze the
sentiment of every word in the sentence
so we saw that also quite strangely they
the dementia sufferers tended to have
more positive sentiments then than their
partners now it could be because of the
sort of state of mind it could be
because the partners are more worried
than they are they give many other
reasons it could be just noise in the
data at this stage so but that's sort of
initial patterns was seeing so a couple
of other features things like go ahead
words of this sort of thing you wrote a
function to sort of count these in the
post because that's the feature of
outside sufferers according to several
papers
so we looked into yo without Simers you
tend to get a loss of lexical functions
or vocabulary tends to diminish and
people tend to use words out of place so
they might use words that they've come
up with themselves or words that really
aren't relevant to what they're talking
about and then there's general
comprehension of what they're saying so
something like a readability metric
should help us with that so readability
metrics we we found a quite a good
package called readability lxml it runs
all of these metrics for you straight
away on on the text and here's a couple
of them plotted so what what we see
again is is reflected once more so
there's greater variation within the
dementia set in in all of these metrics
but the DeMint there's a tendency for
the strangely the complement
comprehension to be so it's slightly
harder to read so so the readability
metrics are aimed at matching sort of an
age group as in people aged 13 to 16
would have no trouble reading this or no
it's actually only people aged 10 to 13
could read this so we found that the
dementia text was actually harder to
read so without trying to read too much
into the the reasons behind this we
explore the data a bit further
supporting plotting on two dimensions
these are these are individual posts
plotted so these are different metrics I
don't if you can read the axes but
there's things like Dale Chow
readability which is made up of the
number of difficult words
and the number of words per sentence so
you see the interestingly and
encouraging you see the dementia the
sort of increased variation it's almost
like the dementia sufferers poster sort
of breaking away from the norm as it
were that's what we could see so after
exploring the data sort of post by post
yeah oh yes so there's a memory or into
the feature as well so we just did a
very simple comparing we just use pandas
group by and ordered ordered all the
posts and for each user week we
somatically compared the post of the
previous post using cosine similarity
which is converting two vectors there
and I tried another one a part of NLT k
package the edit distance which i think
is related to the number of characters
you'd have to rearrange in sentence to
make it match the previous one so this
is to do with people repeating
themselves basically and they see if we
can quantify that way to that
so thinking about in terms of how we
have the feature set what are we doing
here we are we trying to make a
prediction of whether someone has
answers and we're trying to just explain
the causes well in fact we we need to
undertake both approaches so we start by
training a classifier to find out which
variables influence out Simon's that we
can see and this will be explanatory and
then eventually we need to work on a
predictive power in terms of determining
you know when when it went is out so I
was starting to happen in somebody puts
an unknown so in terms of our initial
explanatory modeling phase we want we
started by aggregating the users data so
we took median values and so for each
user we took all their posts and worked
out the median of the relevant metric
and we did some sampling we do that we
had a holdout set as well and yep this
is the monarch alarm system is operating
in city gate house they do not use the
links between these buildings until
further notice okay so the model results
so besides the group are features into
difference the fire alarm system is
operating in city gate house just going
on through that so the first group were
the sort of miscellaneous features so we
put sentiment and the first metrics I
showed you so we we just put if we we
ran a few different classifiers and the
results were not their great as you can
see this ROC curve it's not brilliant
the sentiment came up as top this seems
to be
of differentiating factor then we looked
at the memory features slightly better
so sixty-three percent accuracy but the
precision isn't amazing and it seemed to
be this cosine similarity metric we
tried the mean and the standard
deviation to counter for the fact that
the weed aggregated the data and just
the mean on it so he wasn't telling us
much that came up on top the readability
features once more aggregated not so
great against a fifty-nine percent but
this Dale chels readability the one I
plotted earlier this is a feature
importance we were just using the random
forest function to be able to explain
importance of features it came out it as
a very important metric and then we did
some parts of speech so breaking settles
down determining what what type of each
word as we looked at adjectives nouns
pronouns and verbs and where it was a
calculated a rate as in how many verbs /
how many words in the sentence within a
post and then aggregated over all posts
for that user and
so what two minutes left so yeah we
found that this support vector machine
radial basis function seemed to seem to
do the best but again not brilliant and
when we combined all of the features
into one model you yeah so we're getting
about sixty-three percent accuracy and
there's a sort of a mixture of between
readability sentiment and memory
features coming up so we but we had a
slight change in tech we decided to
classify posts and not users but the
problem is we found that so many more
there are many more partners than
dementia sufferers on the forum and in
general partners were writing three
times as many posts that as as dementia
sufferers so we had to sort of do this
double round of sampling so to even up
our data set but that paid off and we
got a sort of accuracy of up to sixty
eight percent with a random forest
classifier and this is the only slide
one brave enough to put a confusion
matrix on because the results were
getting looking a bit more encouraging
and the memory feature came up top so
just to just to wrap up memory based
features seem to do the best and the
best performing individual feature was
verbreitung the case of aggregated data
but if on individual post it was cosine
surrounded to a previous post and this
this falls into line with what we
determined in terms of early symptoms
so we want to look into many future
avenues including grouping of users
improving every phase of this pipeline
so getting better data to start with and
classifying users to start with in a
clever of fashion we want to collect
more features we want to do different
kinds of classification and move on to
the predictive element which will
probably involve some kind of time
series analysis so we thought about we
noticed this dementia sufferer here if
you they've been posting a long time on
this forum and we see like an increase
in in the in the variance so maybe
that's going to be a way to detect for
certain features it might be a change in
the mean like a brand some things that's
something want to look at so i think i
have to finish that we're all done so
thank you for listening to us where we
sort of giving you an introduction to
art simons some of our initial findings
from this very small side project it's a
tough problem where we think is
worthwhile if if any of you would like
to help and you think you can do this a
lot better than us then please get in
touch it can come and chat to me
afterwards or drop us an email online
through the links thank you very much
thank you very much that was fantastic
so yes and we don't have a roving mic so
just try and speak up if you can
that's right yes
no it's it was purely for you through
ease of use in our case so it probably
doesn't relate to the different
classifiers yeah certain classifiers we
found that aren't very good for a sort
of explanatory problem they're more a
sort of black box give them some inputs
and get some outputs so we were just
using the random forest as a way of just
comparing the groups of features as we
went through
that's true so somewhere around eighty
percent or would be great the key is to
just eventually this might turn into an
application so we just alert people it
might say to you after reading your
emails for a few months you might say
well can you can you make an appointment
with your GP I'll just go and have a
chat and so it's I suppose it's better
to get error on the side of say eighty
ninety percent so this is really more of
a curiosity than something deployable
and it's a very long way off that
obviously in anything medical any false
positives or any false negatives are a
big issue and tend to scare people so
you know there's massive doses of
caution would need to be applied to
anything that comes out of the other end
of this
that they use verbs a lot outside people
diagnosed with outsiders
I think that so that was I think feature
importance of the different features
which is not the same as a predominant
those features are the nouns and the and
the verbs so yeah and it's just nice to
be it was what it was did where did you
see it earlier on did you but it's just
it's just interning that it's we don't
know whether it's more or less actually
it's just determining but it was
important in the classified words to
describe natural lines and I was
wondering if you're interested in
looking at that kind of thing will have
looked at that point definitely yes
thank you so are you working this are
you working in this domain I mean I'm
not specifically with Alzheimer's
dementia but with another type of
dementia and people who have most types
of dementia are likely to use
a word like animals very sample to
describe a dog right which a neuro
logically healthy person would not do
they would say the specific word dog or
even you know Labrador or whatever and I
was just wondering if you looked at what
kind of words they use when they talk
about natural things we haven't gone
into that level detail the one thing
that comes to mind is that they did tend
to use more difficult words and fewer
common words I don't have that tallies
though with what you're saying words
that are less that's right in the
English language yeah thank you
take the text blob yeah
the experience was that it was very easy
to use and to get set up you don't yeah
it's it's got its own pre pre sentiment
analyzed vocabulary so you can just
throw it a sentence and it will it'll
return the not not not not as yet but
that's it's good it's on the list yes
yeah do you have any recommendations
okay
right yeah so we have thought about that
and we want to add more forums so that
are unrelated the thing about the
partners is that they're of a similar
age group usually to the dementia
sufferers so there are presumably
factors that occur just a standard
decline for during old age so that was a
way of normalizing that but yeah you're
right they're going to be worried and
that's why they're hosting three times
as much maybe it's and yes it's
definitely a factor so yeah so different
forums there was one like I'm a carer of
an alzheimer patient and yeah we may
just pick some completely unrelated ones
just to see how they'd have the features
tally pledges more questions and then
they get paid fed and watered sir
similar thing where you look at
for now we've just used the simple the
output from the random forest in
scikit-learn with the only thing we did
was to to group the features initially
and try them out in several groups so
that would give us an indication of the
sort of main areas but you're right we
should do some more careful feature
selection and and observe the impact on
the model directly yeah run it
feature
right
yes yeah there's various approaches you
can have a chat after as if you like
them I just wanted to add to that we've
done very little in the way of
optimization we haven't done proper high
parameter searches you know very much
from the sort out the methodology and
then we've just thrown the data at
classifiers and seen what's come out
with practically no tuning so it's not
very sophisticated at this point so we
probably have to wrap things up can we
have another round of applause for our
great speaker